hey guys welcome to day one at CES I'm
Justine and this is Jenna it's me Jenny
we are heading to get our uber right now
it's really riveting content CES vlog
starting now we're looking for a Ford
Explorer
[Music]
Wow hey give it a shot of the flog
yeah I'm 40 even have them going the
right way
[Music]
okay let's go to the first place that
we're heading down that we're heading to
the Mercedes booth that they have a
press event right now and then after
that we're gonna be heading to Samsung
and then in between that I don't know
what's gonna happen your guess is as
good as mine we have 15 minutes to find
where we need to be you guys have to see
what Nick looks like right now
if you shaved your head we just got out
of the mercedes-benz press event a lot
of you guys don't even know what car I
Drive but I have a DLE 43 I've been a
huge Mercedes fan pretty much my entire
life
my grandmother she drove a diesel
Mercedes it was like a 1970 something
that was my first car I feel like for me
Mercedes has a huge place in my life
this is an example of a new dashboard
this is the MV UX which is the new
interface for Mercedes I love that it's
like this huge screen is basically
taking over your dashboard they have all
new updated graphics and one of the
things that I love the most is it has
natural intuitive language you can
actually have a conversation with your
ease
[Music]
okay we gotta find through two six zero
zero two it's in the South Pole no but
look at this this way to South Poles no
there's an exit over here that takes us
through hi how are you good thank you do
you know what the South Hall is is it
this way or is it this way is out that
way as an added bonus this year's the
yes there are torrential downpours it
hasn't rained in 118 days in Las Vegas
we're not even going that far South Hall
correct okay thank you even the wrong
way I'm laughing I'm laughing but I'm
not laughing
this is like my 70s you think I'd get a
handle on the four hours later we
finally made it to the GTI booth they
announce two things here at CES the new
Ronin s and the Oslo local two so first
let's check out the rodent s
[Music]
single and healthy SLR type system it's
so powerful that can carry all have your
goalie
camera setup present full turn until the
indicator turns it yellow compromising
okay a sport mode as if that's not one
of my favorite features in any drone
you've got it here this is incredible
how does it work
if we want to do a selfie blogging thing
you're cool tap this trigger yeah it
would instantly spin the camera around
to do a selfie that's awesome so kind of
just like dog food
so this is awesome a local to you guys
may have seen I've definitely talked
about the one before but there are a
bunch of differences between this mostly
the price the original last mill was
$2.99 this one wait for it 1:29 you can
use it vertical you can use it
horizontal and another thing that is
pretty awesome hold on I have an active
track right now so it's trying to track
you so much like the original ASIMO give
you triple tap it'll switch to selfie
mode
triple tap we're gonna go back right
here on the side we have a zoom which is
pretty awesome this is all happening
real-time in the app there's also a
little joystick right here where you can
use that to navigate and you can always
hit the trigger which is now right here
as opposed to it used to be right here
on the front the battery is built into
this one and you can get about 15 hours
of battery life and that'll take about
two and half hours to charge I'm pretty
sure up fifteen hours I can probably get
a full day of logging
[Music]
this is something that we actually saw
the other day and it was making headline
news and people were really excited I've
also ran into some people today that
said this is so far one of their
favorite things at CES this is the DJI
copilot can you tell us a little more
about it yes so lysse develop this
before us it's called the DJI copilot
Oracle it has a battery built-in so you
don't need a PC essentially to take any
data off it so what you do is any camera
that you have any drone that you have
you're capturing the data you're putting
on the SD card you then take the SD card
pop it into the new copilot drive so
this has a little display on it - yeah
so there's an e-ink display and so it's
got a six-hour battery you can ingest
the data through an SD port through USB
C or the USB 3.0 jack and then all that
data then you can manage through an iOS
device it has a lightning cable you plug
it into your iPad pro or your iPhone and
then you'll be able to then bring that
data over to your phone or device and
then you'll be able to edit on the fly
that's awesome would I be able to copy
data from here to another hard drive you
can if your device is running low like
your your iPhone there you can actually
use it as a battery pack oh my gosh this
is incredible
okay touch it like so you guys know how
many of those the orange Lacey drives
that I have I mean abundance but I feel
like this is such an incredible solution
especially for traveling on the go even
like here at CES we've been shooting so
much stuff it'd be great to have that as
a backup so is there an internal hard
drive in here already there is yes 2
terabytes care about the mechanical
Drive I think it's a 7200 rpm
we want to get that so you can hit yes
and so just click it once and then now
it's suggesting that's amazing look at
this now their specific app that it uses
there is an app coming
not been officially released yeah so
that'll be coming big when the ships in
March wow you guys have a release date
do it on March 20th that's my birthday
I appreciate it I'll let you guys know I
like about you to my birthday party just
not really great fancy meal here at CES
a play to meet some coffees some cookies
this is living the dream okay just one
bite
I'm so happy I was really a good bite
[Music]
the new Samsung booth here it's a little
bit different in previous years because
they're not focusing on just one thing
they're focusing on the connectivity and
interaction of all of the things all
together and it's really loud so I don't
even know if you can hear me but let's
just head in and see we can see this
right here
I think it's a highlight so far my CES
this is the wall it's the new Samsung
television that was announced here at
CES its 8k 146 inch micro LED television
and let me tell you what this thing is
beautiful pretty sure this is something
that I need in my life immediately can
you imagine playing Mario Kart on this
thing a dream come true one of the
things that I like the same thing it's
doing is they're kind of bringing all of
these things that you may already have
and bringing it into the Samsung
ecosystem so they're basically
connecting things that you already have
that aren't necessarily Samsung and
being able to connect them to everything
this is like an exploration of my house
right now
this rear view mirror is not a mirror at
all it's a display and there are cameras
and sensors all around the vehicle to
give you much more accurate depiction of
what's happening around your car I'm a
terrible driver this is something that I
need in my life
immediately I'm not talking to myself I
promise I look so silly okay so we're
here CES 2018 if you haven't been able
to tell already and I've had some new
friends here at CES and we're going to
just go around this lovely little circle
here and say what your favorite thing is
that you've seen so far the wall
really awesome ovaries will say Raisa
has this massive mechanical keyboard is
quite interesting did you see the razor
phone that connects the laptop that
looks amazing just mingi
did you see it in action
yeah really tell us about it oh no
that's not my favorite thing okay okay
what was your favorite thing
DJI and Seagate whoa Laci we've done
this whole is called the co-pilot and
you don't need your laptop you just copy
straight to my memory card school you
can just take our game here in the Mayan
area of the Samsung booth there is a lot
going on there's a lot of food and
there's a lot of tech those are
basically two of my favorite things
something that I thought was very very
interesting is you can use bigsby take a
picture of your food and will give your
your calorie count now not only that
it'll take you over here to you're
connected refrigerator it'll show you
the picture that you took from your
phone will integrate into the fridge
it'll show you the picture that you took
and it will give you suggestions on
things to cook for dinner say you're
trying to reach a 2,000 gallery goal
it'll give you examples of things that
you should eat for the rest of the day
to meet that goal something else that I
saw was pretty incredible if you want to
cook that meal you can preheat the oven
using your refrigerator this is gonna
elevate my cooking videos to some level
it'll be a tech level but is the cooking
gonna be good probably not so by me is
the sampling family held refrigerator
you guys have seen similar things to
this before I've talked about it I think
it's fantastic and my fridge does not
look this immaculate you guys have seen
inside of it and it's a mess so what's
cool about this there's cameras on the
inside as you can see them they're right
here took out some celery and now the
photo is updated to show you what is
curly in the fridge takes about eight
seconds so you should always know what's
in your fridge
so that's our Samsung booth tour here at
CES 2018 let me know if you guys have a
favorite thing what is something that
you are most looking forward to that was
announced here at CES or that you've
seen
at the sampling booth that's it I'll see
you guys in some more CES videos time
you'll see more cool stuff
[Music]